Paris Hilton says Lindsay Lohan crashed
her girls night out with Britney Spears
in 2006 they're not on the list the
heiress is throwing a little shade at
lilo eleven years after this pic went
viral yep that's Paris lilo and Britt in
a new interview with MTV Australia
Hilton revealed the girls night out was
only intended for two well actually
we'll just Britain my out and then she
just like chased us to the car and got
in she wasn't invited in November hilton
announced on Twitter that she and Spears
invented the selfie that same year
writing eleven years ago today me and
Brittany invented the selfie
as for Lohan she recently told et that
she's loving her life in Dubai I do love
the serenity and peace that I find
living in the Middle East because there
are no cameras in Dubai and I can
actually focus on what I want to do in
life and I don't have to always be
scrutinized every second so I can have a
private life and and have a public life
but what I choose to and I think that's
really important
[Music]
you